good morning today is gonna be a fun day
today I'm gonna watch my friends Steffy
Cohen
um fight in her next profile I think
this might be her third or fourth time
fighting
um so super excited I get to dress up I
just want to show you a little preview I
don't know what I'm gonna worry yet I
didn't go shopping for this one so I
have some high-waisted
fun see blog ponds but then I'm also a
crazy so I got some glitter pants
I'm not sure if I'm really digging them
yet but they're coming with me I have
like this super Borat
thong looking thing that goes like all
the way to my below my boob
type of top
see what that looks like I don't know if
I want to get a little BDSM
on a I was thinking of
throwing this it'll like
vest so imagine my boobs here and then
this vest kind of like Plumping them up
I don't know I don't know what kind of
mood I'm in but it's definitely dark and
a little bit kinky
and then we got like this high
what are these called shoulder
padded
business vest
that I got maybe years ago and I've
never ever worn it is there a tag in
here yep of course there's a tag so
finally have an excuse to wear it
um never worn these either dude I am
annoying look at that brand you
and I think I've had him for like three
years
so yeah this is so BDSM like
it does not make any goddamn sense okay
so that's like the black look
but
if I don't want to go too dark I have
like this beaded thing
here that goes kind of like a what is
this called
like this
a bunch of beads a bunch of balls across
my chest you know what I'm saying it
goes like this I have like a cute little
glitter bra that goes over it or if I'm
not kinky enough
and I'm too much of like a wuss to wear
like just a little bralette
then I have like this body suit that's
like in this bronze color
I still don't know if I have the right
shoes I haven't gotten a pedicure and I
don't want to wear open toe shoes
because it just is not a cute look look
it oh my God I'm about to color briggy
and I was about to call it Fawn but it's
Mia
this chick has
the hardest RB come here the hardest RBF
I've ever seen hey Mia
hi hi Mia
come
yeah RBF harder than this RBF harder
than that
she's beautiful
anyway
um
whoops
yeah so I don't know what shoes to wear
with this I mean I guess black still I
don't want to open toe shoes because
it's just not
so I gotta figure it out but I don't
really have time because it is 7 30 I'm
trying to hit the road
by eight did I mention that it's in
California yes
hey oh that's not all BF this is a cute
BF a cute BF a cute BF
say hello hi everybody my name is Mia
my name is Mia and I like to play
I'll be back
[Music]
oh I feel like someone's behind me oh no
there's another cute puppy
hi cutie Pootie
no he fainted
Mia
she got you with her paw
okay time out we gotta pause
are you okay
what does she hit show me your ear
Mia are you sorry look look at her paws
she wants to touch you she goes she goes
I'm so sorry Taiko us dogs play
different than you that's why
we're just trying to talk it look look
she goes please please forgive me no
do you want are you sorry Mia are you
sorry you see
look look
she said I'm so sorry
she's talking to you she says look look
her head's down she goes I feel bad I
didn't mean to hurt my friend
[Music]
anymore that's not oh I don't see look
I've never seen her like that can you
apologize she's gonna be nice to you
yeah it's because you guys just played
different okay
you see she has claws and fur and big
teeth so her type her version of gentle
yeah so she can hear really loud but her
gentle yeah her gentle is different than
yours that's why see we don't have fur
or sharp teeth we're kind of weak babies
compared to animals no tail no tail at
all look at our ears are so little we
can't even hear as good as them
we just have to play different okay
okay she doesn't understand
I want to wrestle her she'll probably
like it
would you like to wrestle
no she's Jesus
nothing oh my God that's her stomach
does your stomach I you guys are both
little puppies I don't know who's who
I'm not a puppy
a little bit I see it right here look
hey are you excited to go to California
okay so she nips back you know what's
gonna happen look she's coming
don't push her like that be nice okay
see she's ready to play at any time
all right
man she's ready
yeah she's gonna bite it hey hey
hey
um
it's not a real bite it's a little it's
a little nibble
it's a hard day
[Music]
it's not a bite at all she's just
playing
I'm gonna get something okay Mia come
sit
stay
yes
no no Mia come sit sit down
stay
good to go I don't know if I could say
he's gonna get something we don't know
what he's getting it
let's show wait
I understand
he's coming back
oh what is that don't throw it at her
that was funny
that's a good one that's her little toy
that's her favorite toy that's like her
monkey Cheeto
did you know that that's her monkey
Cheeto look like
[Applause]
every time
it's cute huh
me too
this is cute thank you
this is
[Music]
oh you're this one missing yeah
yeah that's very nice of you
[Music]
oh careful watch the corner of the bed
she's strong huh
you good job
[Music]
good good good
tea
foreign
we are all packed and ready to go
back here
I got up here I got the grandma got the
monkey Cheeto and I got Mia Mia the Mia
Mia
that's real she's ready to go that's her
bag Tiger's got all his glasses his
water his toys
oh they're not glasses
and your iPad yeah those are glasses
okay
let's go
okay so we got gas we got a couple
snacks AKA water something sweet
something salty you know what I'm
talking about but now we need to get
McDonald's because this Duty wants what
do you want monkey
what do you want okay
pancakes so the dude has to get pink we
need pancakes in our life
pancakes pancakes what do you want
you look so cool
the aftermath
taika ate the big breakfast all by
himself okay mine is like half of the
eggs and one pancake but everything else
he devoured it oh and the what is this
called again what is this called
the hash brown he didn't eat that I
don't eat that either I don't blame him
it's not that good fight me I said it
we have made it to California in one
piece and you know who's super ecstatic
out of the four people well
out of four people three people are
super ecstatic number one Mia is so
excited to be here because she gets
reunited with her friend
Shadow and they've been playing the
whole time yep that's
that's someone's fur
they just play the entire time
cuties number two grandma because she's
back oh my God look at poor monkey
Cheeto
that is horrible
look at this
that is horrible okay Grandma's the
second person that is happy to be home
because this is her house so she's happy
to be home the third person who is not
even here and I just spoke about them
taika taika right now is on his way uh
he went with his Thea
his aunt to um pick up his cousins from
school they get out
soon so he's with her right now picking
them up and they're gonna be so excited
to see each other uh he was about to eat
lunch like literally was about to sit
his little stinky butt in the chair to
eat lunch and then she walks and she was
taika you want to go pick up the uh the
boys she's like Mom please can I'm like
you have to eat dude and I could see the
the Despair and the excitement you know
like the despair if I say no and the
excitement if I say yes and he's like
Mom please Mom please I was like
all right dude go so the house is really
quiet without him but we're safe we're
here I'm about to take a shower
and look like a woman
put all the makeups on you'll find on
all the makeups put them all on and
hopefully
I will convince people that I'm a woman
and no longer a creature
I need to document this because it's not
the best lighting hold on
okay
the ice cream man's here but
the makeup
oh my God I have all this like mascara
little dots
[Music]
this light is Harsh bruh maybe it's just
my face oh my God this lighting is blue
the
there we go okay
[Applause]
okay I gotta change
I'm ready I didn't know what to wear I
bought this as a costume it's this
corset type yeah this is that oh
yeah it looks good but I covered it with
the Blazer I've never worn These Boots
so we just I don't even know you had a
Blazer like that where'd you get that
from it's like a lot of BDSM kind of
vibrator yeah but we're running late
yeah I just got here she fights at seven
oh and yeah it's 602 oh oh but
you know fights are always late too yeah
or they're well this one's a UFC Fight
Pass yeah so it has to be at seven oh
okay
[Applause]
hold on
what's up
[Applause]
[Music]
um
[Applause]